(crowd applauding)
- It's so nice to meet you.
- It's so great to meet you.
- I'm such a fan.
- Oh really? I love your pink.
- Thank you!
- Pink and pink,
you've gone the whole...it
looks so good on you.
- Thank you!
You have such a like,
delight set.
- It's very colorful.
- So that's why.
- Thank you, I like color.
It makes me happy.
I heard that you're a singer
yourself though, as well.
- Wow, I thought I was.
I used to volunteer and
sing at like nursing homes.
- Yeah, me too, growing up.
- For Christmas.
I used to do that without my church.
- Yeah.
- One of them yelled
and said, "Shut her up!"
- Like they were extreme.
- Oh My God!
- At that point in life,
they don't edit anymore.
- Oh my God.
That was actually what I loved about it.
- Yeah, but you can sing.
Your voice is extraordinary!
- No, no, no.
No, no, no.
That's what I loved about it
being at like those places
because I'm like, man, when I'm old,
I'm gonna have so much.
- Oh you gonna let it rip.
Oh yeah
- Yeah, yeah.
Cause they were so mean, but you loved it.
- Not all of them, it was
just a couple of 'em were like
kind of like mean funny.
- Yes.
And I was like, that's funny.
- I kind of, yes.
Like I couldn't be mad.
Like I can't sing, as
well as I can in my head.
- Oh see, I always
heard you actually sing.
(Kelly laughing)
So I wasn't.
- No, I did sing.
- Okay.
- And I do think I can sing.
You know what it is?
Let me do this.
I can sing.
- Okay.
- I don't have pitch.
- Okay, so you really paid attention
to that Bible verse make a joyful noise.
- Yes! Yes!
- Not a perfect one.
- Yeah, yeah that's all right
- There it is, that's all I was doing.
- That's all right.
- That's all I was doing.
- He hears you and he loves it.
- Yes.
- She loves it.
Whoever loves it.
- Yeah.
So well, your new job.
I hear that you're hosting the Oscars.
This is amazing with Wanda.
(audience Cheers)
Yeah, that's amazing.
- Yeah there they are!
- I'm so excited about this.
cause one, I don't think there's ever been
like three women to host like the Oscars.
I don't think that's ever happened?
- No its never happened.
And you're all three really funny.
I'm so excited about it.
Are you nervous about it?
'cause here I've had to host something
and I had to trick people
because when they asked me to host,
I was like, I'm not a comedian.
I'm like, I'm not like
you, I can't do that.
So I decided to sing
because I thought I
could get away with it,
cause I'm like, well that's my thing.
- Maybe I should do that.
- Exactly, please do.
- Get that lady from the nursing home,
back in that audience.
- Oh my God
- Shut her up.
- But are you nervous?
cause I know that people
like to rip on people.
People like to have a
good time with people.
- I mean, yeah.
I think you can't not be a little nervous
'cause you want it to move,
you want people to enjoy themselves,
and although, I mean, I am
with two stand up comedians.
- Yeah.
- So you know-
- But you are very funny.
You're all funny.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I expect you to rip a little.
Oh no, but I want y'all
to do that a little bit.
- Yes.
- Like for fun,
- No we will
- It's fun.
- No, no, we will.
- I hate when people get mad,
like all you're celebrities that get mad,
you know what your lives are awesome.
Let us poke fun at you.
We wanna poke fun at us.
- Yes!
(audience applauding)
- Like it's fun.
- It's true.
March 27th, will be-
- We know you're human,
but March 27th, just show up ready?
- Yes.
- Just show up ready
- Yeah.
- That's all I'm saying it's okay.
Well your new movie it's called "Master",
so what can you tell us about it?
- "Master" is the fun loving tale...
No, no master.
- I was like, wait, what?
(Regina and Kelly laughing)
That was like,
- No, it's like a creepy kind of drama,
but it's a thriller,
and it's about what
happens at this, Ancaster
which is an Ivy league, you know
a fictitious Ivy league university,
and the experiences that
these three women have there.
- Yeah so wait have you ever experienced
anything like supernatural?
- You know I have a couple of times.
So when I was little,
this is the first one.
When I was little, my best friend in IP,
she was there obviously.
And we were about four and
six and we were taking a bath
in the bathtub playing
and a shirt flew in, arms outstretched,
Pia you know this, wherever Pia is,
arms out, stretched,
hovered over the little tub,
and then it fell in and like whatever
you're four and six is not that scary.
But when I-
- What that is scary at four!
- But not when you're little,
you're like, I don't know,
or maybe we weren't that bright.
(audience laughing)
- Maybe you're just like,
is that supposed to happen? Like wait?
- I think we weren't there.
I'm looking back, I'm scared now.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's terrifying.
- And Pia is in education.
So that's even scarier
(Kelly laughing)
if we weren't that bright!
But I think where I live now,
I definitely have like spirits.
- Well maybe they follow you.
- People have come in.
Oh, I got something.
(Kelly and the crowd laughing)
- But there is a guy, listen,
this is...I can't, don't please.
All right, maybe I am crazy.
I've already told you I'm slow
(Kelly laughing)
'cause when I was six,
but he does like,
if you have antiques and stuff
like he cleanses them.
- Oh.
- And so he came in
and my friend was like,
"You've gotta get your house cleansed",
and so he comes in and he
like puts one and he's like,
(Regina blowing air)
and then, I mean, at one
point he started sneezing,
I was like, he's gonna die in my house,
at a prayer cloth that I had.
- Yeah.
- Like a Tibetan prayer cloth.
And then he just said,
"Lotta, lotta spirits,
lotta, lotta spirits".
And so apparently when you
buy antiques, the energy,
Even physics will say that,
the energy of those things
sometimes remain so,
- Wow!
- Yeah.
- I will forever buy new.
(everyone laughing)
That's all I got from that.
(audience applauding)
All I got.
Yep, brand spanking new for me.
- That just made me thinking
I could send antiques
to like an ex.
- Exactly.
(Kelly laughing)
It's got bad energy.
- Yeah, yeah.
A little wedding gift for you
and your new love.
(Kelly and the audience laughing)
- A damaged, tainted clock.
(Regina laughing)